hey guys Ryan right here Dan Seibert
here
alright so everyone's requesting that we
check this out Star Wars Battlefront
survival mode gameplay III 2015 release
this why talk more to online co-op or by
a split screen there are several unique
types baptists where you and a friend go
head-to-head supported by a team of AI
hear about things where you face off as
iconic characters like Luke Skywalker
and Darth Vader Luke Skywalker issues to
learn and massive escapes needed on the
battle for survival which are debiting
here today let's take a look get some
gameplay
[Music]
well that looks bigger than
[Music]
the folks do but it looks like they have
a pyometra huh I look so real hey Cherie
yeah I do know
oh my god defend the heart my sweet
sweet
[Music]
detonator brow
[Music]
got you
[Music]
[Music]
the orbital strike or not just shoot
them I wish I could see their face right
now
[Music]
I live out my life
Luke Skywalker dude this game Wow in a
day and age when games are constantly
being called they look like Halo or they
look like Call of Duty this shooter game
does not look like a lot of games it
looks so good I feel like we're now into
the next-gen like like balls deep in it
III like that term I know I I use that
just for you I constantly go balls deep
I know you do the gameplay looks great
it looks fun it feels like what Star
Wars originally felt like you know where
it was rather toned down like just the
right amount of design right amount of
effects and then we got it's like
episode 1 2 & 3 where it was like
bombarded and a lot of the games to go
around I got this one I mean glad it was
just one scene we saw one gameplay
section we saw but for my personal
opinion from just seeing that it looks
like it's a little bit more toned down
which I like it's like if you took base
star wars like episode well what is it 4
& 5 technically yeah you take those and
then you just slightly amplify amplify
it because we have better technology
than we did in the past yes like that's
what you get there's nothing like 6
Jabba the Hutt's with laser shooting
from there that's you know I wouldn't
mind that Kim you know what I like it
actually switches back between third
person the first person yeah that's
really cool yeah that option always
makes me feel better I know in
battlefield 2 when my brothers and I
would play we play in the third person
or Battlefront 2 so it's same developer
we used to play in the third person but
then I got battlefront 2 for the PC and
I was back in the first person because
it felt a little better but being able
to choose your your play style and how
you want to do you know tackle the game
you know says a lot that you know
there's other options on how to tackle
anyway guys thank you so much for
bombarding me with requests for that
fact if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Dan's gaming channel then
cyber Channel check it out let's blaze
you know and you should you should
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine because if we get enough
followers we can make money off product
placement
got in it already keep a little go Peter
of gaming hi awesome stuff Ryan love
your reactions as well as all of the
jokes
lol e Yad e God did I get a shout-out I
don't know ma you're awesome dude
congrats on your first 1 million views
check out Veronica's channel her voice
is amazing indeed like you said Oh her
voice is amazing anything with
Veronica's mouth is amazing you know
what I mean Jesus you know what I mean
this is called respecting your
girlfriend Pete ro gaming thanks man I'm
assuming you're a gamer too which means
you probably like Dan just spend all
your time online pornhub.com redtube
calm youporn calm xvideos calm to me
calm bigblackcock calm i don't know why
he goes on there but he does are you
confusing me with you right
take care feature